and I don't and the woman that I want is
definitely not an album I want a
feminine one we don't talk about
feminine women no more because women
want to be men when's the last time we
had a conversation about femininity no
because y'all want to be so masculine I
got to be masculine because of this I
gotta be masculine because of this I'm
an alpha woman because of this when are
we gonna get back to talking about
femininity
women
allow men to do this you get what I'm
saying a man only do what you allow him
and make him feel comfortable with doing
huh yo
do you think that's true what up guys
welcome to the just curly things YouTube
channel um today I am reacting to a new
show I've never actually heard of this
show before but they had like a super
viral panel and I don't know how I
didn't see it it was like two months ago
um but it's called the modern women and
the Art of deflection so today I'm going
to be reacting to the Daily wrap-up crew
they actually have a really cool spot
going on so you guys should subscribe to
their Channel as well uh pull up the
footage King oh camo hat I like the camo
hat and you want this you remember you
said earlier you want this in a woman
right you need to be fit blah blah blah
what do you bring you fit you go to the
gym yeah I do go to the gym actually I
do go to gym I provide I'm a protector
I'm a leader of my household and I don't
and the woman that I want is definitely
not an album I want a feminine one we
don't talk about feminine women no more
because women want to be men when's the
last time we had a conversation about
femininity no because y'all want to be
so masculine I gotta be masculine
because of this I got to be masculine
because of this I'm an alpha woman
because of this when are we gonna get
back to talking about
this is the thing women will always
blame our shortcomings on men where does
it stem from our own decisions look it
guys I'm a tomboy I've always been a
tomboy and I'll say it was because of my
decision to play sports from a young age
that was what I cared about and you know
I could whine and be like oh boohoo but
it's like all right pick your battles in
life pick your choices it is what it is
but you know you you can always improve
and this is the thing we don't talk
about as women you cannot help where you
start you always start in a certain
place in life but we can always improve
and what I cannot stand is women blaming
the men instead of just looking at
ourselves and wanting to improve I work
hard in my life to make a living and
support for my family I don't give a
[__] about what you had to go through in
your life I need a feminine woman if you
can't beat it
oh
sometimes a woman can talk her out of a
relationship you can talk we we do that
yes we will talk
I'm gonna say something and this my
ruffle Little Feathers I don't think
just being a good man is enough
okay
oh that was the best edit oh that was he
was Gone Too Soon actually when I say
you're good man I mean like I was good
all that means all around that means
himself spiritually mentally physically
that's great he's a good man that
doesn't mean that he's the man for you
right maybe when you're going through
these these are the same women that will
cry about being a good woman and not
being treated right that's the funny
thing is the same woman that'll say oh
being a good man isn't enough it's the
same woman that'll say I can't be a good
woman or I can't be too feminine because
I give him all the power and he might
have been
motions of getting to know him you're
realizing okay he's a great person but
honestly he don't he I don't [__] with
his humor like he could be funny and
that's why a lot of modern women are
getting 40 with with four cats and no
man because maybe that's he's a good
he's a good man but because
You Gotta Throw That wow so get into the
first topic is being a good man good
enough for modern women today that thing
it depends on
depends everybody's standard is
different so I mean it's like contextual
what good is in a man what certain
female might want out of a man I
personally think um I think I think
you're right it does depend on the
person but when it comes to her I think
she was shying I really don't I I I get
where she's coming from where it's like
you know there's there's more to it but
it's like what more should there be you
know if he's a good person he takes care
of you he provides like what else do you
want you know I think everyone has
different needs so then but being would
probably she has to figure out what's a
good man for her like what like she says
a good man is not enough and it's like
this I think this is another big problem
we're having society today everyone
wants to figure out what a word means
for them when words have General meaning
you have good thought you have very very
insightful king that's so true yeah
because it's like what does that mean to
you but it's not like what what does it
mean because they literally just said is
is having a good man good enough really
and truly if if you understand English
there's what is subjective about it oh
my gosh do you know what I just realized
that's what women do when they don't
like the answer they have to give when
the answer makes them look bad they say
well it depends because really she she
wanted to say well no if having a good
man is not good enough but she might
have thought that might sound weird yeah
you sound bad man make me look somehow
so let's give the long-winded answer
what is this what is enough yeah what is
enough for you like what is like what is
he doing that's not enough if you want
something if you don't want a genuine
like and I'm not saying that you can't
get something genuine out of you know
another type of relationship but if you
don't want to be straightforward you
want [__] money you want this you
want that like let's keep it a buckfish
on me don't I don't I don't know I feel
like personally she was just rambling on
from saying what she really wanted yeah
because she mentioned his humor but um
do you feel like you know women Boo the
goal posts when uh when it comes to you
know potentially having a successful
relationship as far as wanting more like
uh like she mentioned he's a good man he
does everything but his humor was the
only thing that was lacking you don't
[__] with his humor and that just and
that's so super perfect like okay even
I've dated I've dated a funny guy before
there's only so long they'll be funny
you've heard all the jokes after a while
you know what I mean like is that gonna
be a make or break in a marriage funny I
don't know you know it's like it can
only be funny for so long got all from
it yeah that's a big thing for her then
she will move the goal post if it's like
whatever then you know she's gonna
override okay but then the answer is no
not enough I want a guy that's funny or
no it's not enough I want a guy that's
this again it depends on like it depends
what she's looking for no he got to be
Eddie Murphy
make a good point
um about women moving to goal post right
because oftentimes on the show we would
hear women say we're all the good men
like there's no good men so now that
y'all found that good man now it's like
well he has all of these he has 98 of
what I want but because he doesn't have
that two percent
um he's just not for me so you were
willing to risk that two percent in
hopes to find the man this 100 man and
realistically I don't think men anybody
is going to find that a hundred percent
person that's compatible with you you
know men or women like you know what I
mean so for you to try to keep holding
out to find that and that's what that's
what I'm finding what's happening a lot
with women is the thing about I'm not
going to settle like you know what I
mean like oh um I'm gonna keep looking
for that unicorn or that goddess Ultra
compatible with me and you're going to
keep getting older and older and now
your options are not even there no more
like you know now that guy that you did
find he may not even want you like that
you get what I'm saying because of
obviously biology and and all these
other factors that you know these guys
that have made enough of themselves as
far as you know if they are successful
and productive in society they do they
have the options now like you get what
I'm saying so now they have the book of
options now do you fit in their options
probably not at that point like you know
what I mean so I just I'm moving the
goal post thing that you was talking
about I just feel like everyone thinks
they have a problem yeah yeah that's
right that is the problem but who do you
think is more of who do you think
realizes that more men or women both
hell no mental realistic you know what
I'm saying I I of course we want
something in return but we're willing to
compromise and I don't want to use
that's not true if you don't find her
attractive are you gonna compromise no
no but that's to like yeah but the bar
for it's not the same because the bar
for men like okay women need to
compromise on attraction more than men
because man it's actually crazy if you
start asking guys like would you how low
they'll go now it might not be on their
best day you know what I mean but it's
actually I started asking guys that this
and it's also kind of crazy if a girl
has like one good body part guys can
Overlook so much like there's this girl
in the shower this is like a year ago
now this is with my old producer but but
I I kind of thought this girl was fat
and he's like oh I didn't even notice
because she had like you know the the
goods you know what I mean and
and
um but what I realized is like guys kind
of have like goggles where it's like
they can kind of get over certain flaws
if they have one thing women it's just
not the same it's like we kind of look
for a reason to disqualify a guy so a
guy could have like five things he that
we want but if he doesn't have the sixth
thing then we disqualify them so women
need to compromise more on looks because
we find 80 percent of men is ugly where
men find like half of women attractive
and honestly I think it'd be even higher
if we weren't so fat like imagine men
find half of women attractive and we're
fat imagine if we were in shape okay so
it's like we have to compromise more on
attraction because we're the pickier sex
we have higher beauty standards whether
we like it or not besides I don't the
reason why I think men compromise a lot
when it comes to looks is because I
think a lot of men understand the fact
that once you get with the woman
um a lot of the time the looks is gonna
Gonna Change anyways because when she's
gonna get comfortable she's probably
gonna have kids so like the look thing
like I guess yeah it helps to get on the
door but men are more able to compromise
because we understand the realities of
life you know what I actually think one
thing that man see men aren't like
attracted to work ethic but I think like
even when my brothers were dating like
one thing I like about the girl that my
older brother's dating is she works
really hard because when you think about
it it's like if she's gonna stay in
shape for a lifetime that's hard work so
sometimes like it's hard though because
men aren't like attracted to that the
way women are but it's like a good
quality so what else is she giving me is
she a good woman is she cooking is she
cleaning is she making me happy or she
[__] me all that other stuff then I
will I will dial down on one ten coming
from all about compromise relationship
is all about compromise there's no agree
100 comfortability 100 like you feel me
I mean there there is people out there
where it's like they find their soulmate
but in reality it's all about compromise
like there's not gonna be absolutely
everything that you like about your
partner but if they're just right for
you they're just right for you if you
can't see that then you know you believe
in soul mates yeah 100 really I feel
like there's seven billion people in
this one I do not do you believe in
soulmates I do not I think you just pick
like I kind of have a weird view on
marriage actually I do believe in
soulmates but I think each person has
like thousands of soulmates
that's what I think about like thousands
of people it would work with yeah but
then I don't think it's a soul mate I
think it's just like I kind of have the
reason why I think it's a soul mate is
because you might have thousands of
people that you could compromise with
and work with but in reality you're
probably not going to meet even like 10
of them yeah that's true I mean I think
there's people you have like chemistry
with like but I don't know I just think
like when you get married I have weird
views on this okay I feel like as a
woman you don't really need to know too
much about a guy to get married I know
as a man you need to know a lot about a
woman because you got a lot more to lose
but as a chick it's like you gotta know
it's like family background you gotta
know he's like a good dude but I don't
think men like change all of the sudden
after six months I think in the first
first like six months to a year you kind
of know what you're gonna get women on
the other hand we can play chameleon we
can pretend to be someone else for like
years I don't know I have like weird but
you can you can pull the video back no
way that there's you can't find someone
but you told my soulmate
I believe like your soulmates can be
friends oh yeah actually but yeah I
don't believe in soul mates because I
think he just picked someone and figure
it out that's that's my my opinion like
it could be multiple it can't it's not
like just romantic you know the
probability it could be platonic you
know what the probability what do you
mean there's platonic soulmate we just
makes [__] up as girls those numbers
seven billion people on this earth right
you know what the probability of you
finding your soul mate I'm not speaking
in literal terms but let's just be 100
like if you are putting yourself out
there it's just like people you have
chemistry that's what I I think soul
mates is just like a different way to
say it people you have chemistry with
that's you're bound to find somebody
that might just be right for you you
know that's just in my opinion
especially if like you're looking in the
right so it's like like to I understand
um compromising is part of a
relationship but it's like when it comes
to the reason why I didn't get what she
was saying is because she was talking
about like little aspects that don't
really matter you know to me like a deal
breaker would be um if he's messy or
like extremely messy though I had um I'm
gonna read you guys a tweet I saw this
is by a woman
um who let me see this was a wife
believed in biblical submission all that
stuff do you expect your husband to help
you with chores if you do you won't have
a happy marriage because expectations
destroy relationships if he helps great
if not do your housework work cheerfully
as unto the Lord remember you didn't
marry your husband to help with
household chores you married him to be
your protector and provider you should
have married him because you deeply
loved him wanted to be great be a great
help mate to him make his life better
not worse and put the burden upon his
shoulder that he already has to K to
carry and providing for his but you know
some reaction channels will say I get
divorced I won't say no games divorce
over over chores right you know pull the
video pull the video the point where
it's um like unmanageable or uh he's on
like not self-aware you'll be surprised
by how many people are not self-aware
you know like those are deal breakers
for me I find that the most not
self-aware people are the ones that say
everyone else self-aware little things
little attributes like him not being
funny okay I'll be funny for the both of
us
we're fine we'll dug it out yeah I
appreciate that what should those scheme
like you said like she looking for like
the perfect man and it's like nobody's
nobody's perfect no I mean she's not
perfect and that yeah and that's the
truth as women a lot of times we expect
Perfection but we're not perfect like is
it fair for a single mother to expect
monogamy I was thinking about this it's
really not a fair trade when when you
think about it because the man has to
compromise on his mating strategy and
raise a kid that's not his like in a way
it's just like reverse cuckold trees
just like agreeing to it um my thoughts
on that is I think I think if if she's
with someone and they agree to enter a
relationship obviously she has to expect
it but that being said I think it should
be in a situation like it should depend
on the kind of man she's getting with so
if she's if she's a single mother and
she's getting with uh probably a
millionaire handsome tall guy and she's
expecting monogamy I mean she should
expect it in terms of what Society
dictates but her actually sitting down
to go for that kind of guy and expect
monogamy it's kind of delusional though
I honestly I think it's almost
delusional to expect it from the average
man she's gonna get it because we live
in this Society but I like I I think
from like a historical point of view and
just it how you know you weren't
monogamous to him by bringing in a child
into the relationship that's not yours
you might be monogamous now but like the
idea of marriage is you're supposed to
be monogamous for a lifetime now you
know the mental put up with the
non-virgins they don't even they're like
whatever we'll get over this but now
you're bringing in a another child the
crazy thing is the men are accepting
this but that's that's a very good point
to make because think about it on the
man's side she's coming with another
man's kid and she expects him to protect
that kid yeah she expects him to provide
for that kid yes she expects all of that
for that kid but she doesn't want him to
get anything on his own yeah and he
doesn't get youth because she's probably
not young she doesn't he doesn't she
doesn't get he doesn't get Purity
because you know she's pushed out
another man's baby how did women
convince men to agree to stuff like that
because we've been telling you guys that
we're Queens for 50 years and that you
guys are like you know Save A Hoe can
and and that's the crazy thing it's such
an unfair exchange like when you think
about it it's like you know when his
what's his mating strategy right to to
spread his seed what's the woman's
mating strategy to get the best possible
guy that she can right with protection
and provisioning now the thing was back
in the day when you brought Purity and
youth to the table like it was fair
because the guy would stop sleeping
around but he would get Purity in you so
she would say you know I'm not gonna go
chase after the billionaires the
millionaires I'm not going to try like
you you're a good bat hopefully in the
future you'll make it and he said you
know what okay I'm not gonna screw all
these hoes you know I'm just gonna have
sex with you and that's my like they're
both compromising but now it's like
women we we're not compromising at all
it's almost like they're saying
um that work hard and get the ducks in a
row get things another don't deserve
women unless they are either damaged or
right or I mean not at their Peak
anymore well how how crazy is it that
Leonardo Cabrio or any like top five one
percent men can't expect a virgin like
think about it like all these women on
the planet now it's not to say that
virgins don't exist but like one even if
a guy says Okay I want a virgin one
where would he meet this virgin how
young would he have to go and is it can
he even believe that she is there's no
way to even you know how does he know
and so it is actually unfortunate I was
thinking about this I was I think it
makes it harder for virgin women too
because a guy that's got his [__]
together one one it's like you might be
an anomaly but there's a million girls
ready to sleep with him down the road
now he's got this system where even if
you are a virgin and he marries you it's
like there's no guarantee that you won't
do crazy [__] after you get married so
that's too much of a concern and then
third of all well he doesn't know you're
not lying you could very well be lying
in my opinion I even think the whole
body count and virginity thing doesn't
really have much bearing on
relationships as much as do laws because
I think even if women were in virgins if
the laws didn't support yeah this woman
would behave yeah I just think yeah
that's what I think I think the laws
just create this environment where
everything could go to [__] but you'll
still be safe I don't know I think body
count does affect it but it's just like
I remember because if she knew that if
she left there will be no help correct
correct correct right but my my thing is
it's kind of like girls that sleep with
over like the biggest drop in
um marital satisfaction is from zero
Partners or from one partner to two so
it's like you're already dropping to
like 50 from 80 to 50 and then after
five you're like done and between five
and like 25 it's basically the same so
guys are kind of like they're never
gonna know anyway so it meant that men
really do adapt to the market because
the quality of women you guys get today
is so bad compared to a hundred years
ago like you guys as grandfather and
great grandpas would be so disgusted by
the level of women that you guys wife
you know and I don't I don't say this to
like people think I say this stuff to
shame people but it's really just an
observation
um it's not to be mean it's just like
you know 85 percent of women were
virgins a year ago now we got men
marrying women on only fans like that's
the that's the level even that girl in
the last clip he's like a low body count
a low body count today what would you
say low body count is today 10. okay 10
men do you realize that would be like
hurray even 50 years ago they they would
throw you out like nobody would talk to
you these are the level of what I'm not
saying this to be mean but just this
isn't good this isn't good for society
wow you think 10 is low I'm not perfect
so how you expecting perfect Guys
somebody else no I mean you gotta be
willing to work and this is the thing
the women will always flip it on the men
and be like but men aren't perfect the
men know they're not perfect that's the
difference like if you said all right
you know the men there's more men that
are unemployed nowadays that's true the
men know this it's like if you said
there's a lack of masculinity today well
King kind of disagreed a little but most
men most men well I mean you'd agree
that men are more feminine right you
don't think so I think it's more of an
adaptation too yeah yeah but because
they're raised by single mothers but you
know you can hear it in guys voices but
you see even those so-called feminine
men if you put them in a group of men
and just give them three months probably
yeah but the pro where would they go
this is the problem is there's you know
because Society is choking out all the
places where men could yeah congregate
and do them yeah and they call it like
toxically masking all this [__] yeah and
so it's but that's the thing I think men
know where they fall short women do not
even like that girl earlier she was
super nice I really liked her she seemed
like sweet like I genuinely liked her
but some of these Concepts she'd never
heard before she was like what do men
want like we live in a society where
we've never even been told what men want
like I think one of the biggest problems
in society today ignorance and I'm not
even trying to
um to be mean or anything but I just
think ignorance amongst women and
dissipating information so I just think
a lot of women are happy living in
ignorance and they don't want to know
the realities but that has a knock-on
effect because I was watching some video
online on Instagram or something where a
woman was talking about if she has homie
Invaders she would she just because she
doesn't want people to get hurt you
rather her man uses hands instead of
using a gun to defend her it's like and
then they asked her so what if there are
five of them and they don't have weapons
but would you rather your man fights
them with his hands or he fights them
with a gun she was like yeah rather he
uses his hands and they say what if what
if he gets killed and she was like well
just because their home Invaders doesn't
mean they're gonna kill him how like oh
I'm sorry it's just it's just weird
because it's like how can you be
rationalizing invaded your home so
you're trying to rationalize and think
in the positive for them I mean we live
in la la land like we just think a lot
of things that don't make sense and then
they'll be like Pearl dude what about
you do you think some things that make
sense and they act like I don't know
what I'm talking about when I got 1.5
million Subs in a year and a half like I
don't say anything that's true now look
it am I still a woman do I still say
things that don't make sense sometimes
sure sure but you have to understand
women we're just so easy to propagate
like you can hear the propaganda just
coming out of our mouths that we just
spew like once you here you cannot hear
it it's like the the manner of men are
it's like you you hear it in every
argument because that's always the like
the gut go-to every time we disagree
with men you know when oh you know I'm
pro-life well what about what about the
grape when the 11 year old gets gripped
what what you should obey your husband
well what if he's gonna like like the
woman said in the um in the audio in the
video if you You're Gonna Be you're
gonna be single with four cats and she's
like I'm fine with that so yeah
right because women don't know the
reality like they don't think of the
reality of singing with four cats or
sitting with four cats because right now
we have Beauty and when you're young and
you're beautiful you're not actually
lonely you know how are you going to be
lonely as a 20-something year old when
you there's a line of guys wanting to
date you a line of guys willing to help
you a line of men giving you attention
all the time but it goes away and what
would your life look like at 50 your
beauty is pretty much gone
um and then they'll be like but JLo
[__] you're not JLo like JLo was like a
nine a 10 back in the day now she's a
six if you're a six you're a two all
right like we're gonna go by you know
and and so so one we we use these people
in media that aren't us that are our
outcome you're not gonna get married at
50. and like we don't think about like
what life really looks like when you're
by yourself that old because as a young
woman I I just think as a young woman
you really can't experience loneliness
the same way men do but we experience it
later on if we don't get married that's
what you're going that's what you're
going to end up with because nobody
perfect so if you're searching for that
perfect [__] you know what this reminds
me of you ever heard of that concept of
like the husband store oh yeah
definitely oh I've heard this yeah I got
your perfect husband yeah like it's like
this every level you go to is like a new
attribute on me and the woman just kept
going until there's nothing left and
they ended up with nothing yeah I think
that's very like because they were
saying the guy is probably if there's
seven levels like the guys will probably
set on on level four like you know what
I'm saying one will get the level four
he got everything I want but let me see
what else I got it yeah let me see
what's up and then and then seven I
there's no men here and then I was like
damn like you kept going up and I think
that's what you know when we talk about
you know hypergamy right women are
naturally hypergamous and I don't think
there's anything wrong with that but
when you're constantly keep trying to
look for the one up you know what I mean
as far as the guy sometimes you get to
the point where you have a good
situation but you're so you oh I'm not
going to settle I'm not going to sell
that mindset so now you keep going up
and then you end up with nothing like
and I feel like women would use the word
settle and men will use the word
compromise when you're looking at a
referral relationship once once a man is
hooked onto a woman we we are willing to
compromise and build you know where
women they feel like they settle in and
once a woman feel like she's kind of
settling she always got one foot in one
foot yeah the relationship's basically
over that's why I don't know some guys
will argue with women to stay like girls
will break up with them and they'll just
like argue for the chick to not leave
it's just like dude like she's not and I
know this because you know it's like you
your friends and you know friends tell
you their son I mean who knows women
exaggerate everything but but it's like
if if she's begging if you're begging
her to leave like she's gonna go at some
point she's just trying to figure out a
better Exit Plan worrying about or or
seeing what other options exploring her
options at all times I have a question
for what you said when it comes to
looking you don't think men like they're
always I mean I hear it all the time
don't you think men have backup plans it
depends on the kind of guy dude you
think top men have backup plans I don't
think they have backup plans like that
active but I know they probably can
replace I think they just know that they
can replace a woman if she leaves but I
don't think they have like backup plans
actively waiting because if a man even
has like girls that are like in the wing
wow he has a girl if the girl leaves I
don't think he's just automatically
going to promote some girl I think he'll
rather check yeah he'll probably go and
meet another girl
okay you wanna know this is the most
unpopular opinion that I think I've ever
had in my life I respect side chick yes
I do now I'm not this now this is not to
confuse me with saying you should be a
side chick this is not to confuse with
that's a good idea this is not even to
confuse with I think this is right but
but not nor nor there's some rumor going
around that I was a side chick to a
married man I was not I'd like to say
not that did not happen but but I think
I think it's because I defend this
sometimes now a good amount of marriages
are sex a good amount of marriage is the
woman does not respect the man now we
don't talk about the women that steal
husbands because the woman was a shitty
wife now I my thing is if if the woman's
gotten fat the woman doesn't respect her
husband and the woman doesn't sleep with
her husband which let's be honest that's
a large percentage of marriages today
can you really can you really fault the
man for leaving when another woman shows
interest now now I'm not saying this is
good I'm not saying this is okay but
it's like you kind of respect the game a
little bit it's like if she steals him
because the wife wasn't doing her job
it's like it's kind of like when the
intern starts working for free
and then replaces the other person
now I know this is an unpopular opinion
now this does not say I'm I'm saying
it's okay or good or you should but you
know I kind of respect it I kind of
respect it is that crazy King is that
he's shaking his head I heard that this
happens in like third world countries
like a western doodle go to like a third
world country and the women there are
just so great to him that he just like
never comes back because he's like oh my
God these women are cooking for me
they're sleeping with me like they're
treating me like a king I've never
experienced this and they just like
don't return ever a great woman where
it's like you know it's perfect for them
but they're willing to risk it for
something extremely temporary so I feel
like that's backwards I can agree with
that I don't think that's that's looking
to like no that's looking to upgrade no
no no no hold on hold on I'll let you
talk
um I don't think it's looking to to like
upgrade or whatever like a woman will
look to upgrade her situation and man
look for like some temporary and then go
back home to his wife but you're risking
it true yeah so at the end of the day it
doesn't matter if it's looking to
upgrade or if you're looking to risk it
you're nah it's so different you know
what I was thinking about I had I had
this crazy two I can't remember what I
tweeted but it was something like
cheating doesn't have to be a big deal
now now everybody freaked out and was
like oh because I said selfish women
will divorce over chores cheating and
like something else now guys a lot of
people misconstrue my view on I think
cheating is wrong I don't think however
I think women we should humble ourselves
in a way you cheated you're supposed to
be a virgin on your wedding night okay
we're not virgins on our wedding night
and yet we're gonna judge men for for
cheating when when we're in a way we're
kind of coming into the relationship
having cheated now maybe you don't view
it like that whatever so but first of
all I'm like let's get off of our high
horses just for one second again
cheating is wrong if if a guy's married
for 50 years and let's just say for six
months that man's a player he's kind of
wild now sleeps with like eight women
and six now that six months is gonna be
hell but in the grand scheme of things
in 50 years does it have to be a big
deal now even or if it's a one-time
thing in 50 years 20 years 30 years
whatever it is if you really want to be
married and when you think about it like
how long was that sex really like he has
sex with her for an hour or two hours
one night but he's with you all the
other nights of the month like how often
can a guy really make time to cheat when
you think I mean I've heard some stories
some guys make the time let me tell you
but but you guys see my point it's like
I'm not saying that you know I would be
so perfect in that situation I probably
would have a very hard time but I think
the goal should be to keep families
together I think the goal should be to
work through cheating and I think the
goal goal should be that you know
sometimes couples do crazy [__] for a
while and they work it out and they
figure it out and I I don't think we
ever hear because people are embarrassed
to talk about you know we did you know
he did cheat for a bit but then we
worked through it and now we're happy on
the other side people to do that so does
cheating now the question is does
cheating have to be a big deal I don't
know is this and and I also think women
would cheat more than men even if we
took social media out of it crazy thing
is women have open dating profiles now
Instagram is the number one dating app
so women are coming in and saying oh he
cheated he cheated
um okay so you don't have an open
Instagram because if you've been open
Instagram anybody can message you you
know that so it's like unless you turn
your message requests off anybody can
message you and it's really an open
profile of you right so you're on the
internet and also accepting attention
from other men I mean how many times do
women go to the gym and flirt with their
trainer they go to the grocery store and
flirt with somebody so it's like again I
just think if we got off our high horses
for a second to see where the men are
coming from it could result in more
relationships plus also it's funny how
women say they want to buy one that
protects them but then they have an open
Instagram how is a man meant to protect
you you're easily accessible to the rest
of the world he's not going to be with
you 247 who only God knows what you're
doing in your DMs when you're not beside
him kind of things you're talking about
the things you're saying about your
relationship to other people only God
knows but it's just interesting because
women will demonize men for cheating yet
they have open Instagram accounts and
honestly even if we took Instagram out
of it it's like even good woman probably
at some point have accepted attention
from another guy and you know I'm just
calling a spade a spit like like okay
the woman was married 50 years and never
flirted with anybody never like come on
like and I'm just I'm just being honest
here never and that's what I'm saying
it's like we'll demonize the men for
cheating but accepting attention from
other men we just like skip over I've
wanted to move the conversation away
from the attention part because people
always want to bring excuses let's even
focus on protection with her open
Instagram she's claiming she wants this
man to protect her this and that this
and that but then you guys go out and
the very first thing you do you what the
city is not even warm you just got to
the restaurant you just sat down you've
already posted a picture with the
location where you guys are
you really you bring in some good points
kid because you can't extrapolate that
idea and put it to sexual part as well
but I just wanted to put it on a
different part so that because I think
once you start talking about the whole
infidelity and stuff like people's
brains switch off but if you can if you
can make the analogy to other more
practical things like safety well I just
think it's it's saying because I don't
even I could even show you married women
that have been on the show it's like we
live in a society where it's acceptable
for a married woman to have an open
Instagram that looks like a dating app
that we don't see the husband anywhere
she's posting cleavage correct correct
or and even in relationships it's like
we expect him to stop sleeping with
other women or trying to we still accept
attention from other men so I don't know
I know the see everyone's like will lose
their mind it's not the same
that's
that's good looking it's
that's not true either but you're
looking so if you wear one but why would
you look then tell me that that's I
don't sometimes sex is just there for
men they're like that's here you know
it's not it's not as deep for them
I can't explain it okay
it's essentially the same thing you're
just we're human different we're human
yeah it looks it looks like a man could
be satisfied with the situation and
still look at something like temporary
I'll get this real quick then that has
nothing to do with his suggestions also
true I understand that doesn't mean he's
not satisfied though that's why I said
it's two different things what is that
you're still risking it so it's like a
woman is risking looking for someone
better and you're still risking yeah but
she will she will leave on a situation I
feel like it sounds even worse in in in
in in the way that you're putting it
right now you will leave your situation
in hopes that this man will be better
that you're talking to with no no
strings attached and you will hope that
this is gonna be a better situation I'm
not leaving myself and you would race
there's men that would risk uh let's say
10 plus your relationship for what a nut
let's be 100 transparent okay then so
yeah but I don't
get that much through when the like like
they're thinking about their 10-year
relationship when the woman like throws
herself at him or whatever however the
opportunity came to be I think I I don't
know I think would guys get in that like
mind frame they're not thinking about
too much else maybe correct wrong but I
don't know that's my opinion double like
you can't no they're both wrong it's no
I'm not saying yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's two different perspectives though
yeah but his point is that they're both
doing they're they're attempting to do
different things he's not looking to
losing situation but it still happens
there's messages
for younger medley for this or you feel
me she got a bigger ass or you know fine
found you know men leave for what they
feel like is better I don't think women
understand women allow men to do this
you get what I'm saying a man only do
what you allow him and make him feel
comfortable with doing huh yo if I I'm
telling you this yo
do you think that's true I think that's
kind of like it like it was not really
so bitter talk like yeah like women
trying to control men I I just think
that mentality goes back to like I think
a relationship is a doomed if a woman's
trying to control a man like I just
think it's not a good expectation so the
idea that like that's kind of feminist
talk like he'll only do what you let him
do like cheaters are gonna cheat it
doesn't matter who you who it is I think
that's part of a narrative that's pushed
to force women to almost want to take
over the relationship because then they
say something like well you you only do
what you're allowing to do then what do
you think women are going to do when
they hear that they're gonna oh yeah
they're controlling you can't go out you
can't do this like you know I have
friends they did like a challenge where
they like were having trouble when
they're married and they just said this
month I'm just gonna be super nice to
him but but I I find that like if you're
just like good to men and like super
nice to them they do more for you in the
long run to be honest but I think
cheaters are going to cheat it you can't
go into a relationship trying to control
people
how many times how many times have you
realistically been cheated on and stood
with the dude and I I honestly I can't
tell you all right well let's ask the
rest of the world in society of women
who stood with a [__] after he cheated
on her and and smiled in her face got
back in the panties and then cheated on
her again after a while it's a it's like
normal it's like regular you know what
I'm saying where as far as when you say
you can't control yourself no no no no
don't put words in my mouth no but don't
know
no I'm and you allow me to [__] other
girls to come [__] you that's what I'm
okay so you can't no no no no no I can
control myself because if I if if
certain people that's in that situation
want to be in that like not do that they
can do that I just think women like
cheaters I think they like the
excitement I think they like the drama
it's like when women tell their cheating
stories they get so happy you don't even
see you smiling right they do they'll be
on the show they're like oh my God he
did this this and this and I'm like why
are you smiling like this is I don't
know I I just think women tend to pick
men that cheat I think if they kind of
like you do not not in the long run
right but I don't know I just think
again why do we keep picking the guys
that cheat if we don't like it it's like
what we say versus what we do I think
I'm good on this clip though for now I'm
kind of getting sleepy
um I like I might continue this reaction
another day when I'm not as tired this
is our last reaction of the day but let
me know what you guys think in the
comments all right like the video on
your way out
um subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next time